all right we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 25 and
it's another glorious Sunday at the
round table
and speaking of Sunday you already know
that this is the Lord's Day suspects at
the round table
my co-host with the co-host my brother
from another mother didn't want a grow
game my man Lord addict how are you
doing sir what's going on you guys
just of course most technical Gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single-player experience semi offline
xbox profile Illuminati
Lord sovereign how are we doing sir wide
awake guys got a good amount of sleep so
I'm ready to go nice levels is up and of
course the excess gamer the Lord who is
a man of his convictions and demands
nothing less than the premium experience
beloved Lord King how we doing sir we do
her fantastic we had another great night
in combat sports last night I know the
UFC has something I have to check that
out today no I'm not saying nothing
small I know it was something that I
wanted to watch so you know I have it
put there for later it was just so much
stuff that was going on last night
you know um that I was watching but as
far as boxing go was on the Espania of a
selling low mischenko one of the
brightest stars in the sport they did
seven to ten of views to ten million
views last night so it was really good
but I know the reason why I want to see
that UFC thing because they talking
about the Daniel Cormier and then
talking about the stars retirement and
um I just want to say that retirement
for that man is so stupid in a sense
that you just didn't beat a better
talent
that's all he wasn't a better fighter
than you he wasn't a better this Oh
better that it was just a better talent
and the skill set on John Jones is
incredible so I don't I don't like the
fact that they're trying to push this
guy will get it to well yeah I know it's
like just when you facing those
once-in-a-generation athletes sometimes
those guys if they can't beat that guy
then their whole thing is like what's
the whole purpose of continuing listen I
had a great week some stuff to get into
a shout-out to anchorman and trying to
finish zero rises on I know your
frustration brother oh I gotta tell you
to promote a fight to promote a match
you have to give and take you can't just
you know say your little quips and go
hide in the corner you you did your
little video you mentioned my name you
called me out you said a challenge that
you will play me with a WNBA teen
brother I accept your challenge but I
all I hear is cricket's brother don't
put nothing out there you ain't willing
to back up listen I told you I will beat
you today to come out I don't play the
game but but kiss smooth man you're
letting the little brothers down and
believe me I'm saying it's kind of
making me nervous that when you do get
beat you might not pay brother I hope
you keep betting brother you know you
know come on man Lord smooth ILP bets
are starting to rack up hopefully BMV a
life thing go down man you got one hour
to pick up that invite to get to the
party I get I get you know the diameters
are the better not but what you guys not
agree to give a [ __ ]
but the parameters of the day somebody
who's been in plenty of best lurking
over the years one thing you need to
recognize be wary of the fine print what
I'm trying to explain is I don't want to
say how you feel that I'm not willing
I'm saying I'm willing ready and able as
soon as that clock go Bing I'm trying to
get in there I'm trying to mix it up
soon as the lights hit but you're
telling me that you want somebody there
to get enough time to put some
performance enhancers in a system he's
going off to do something else is the
real game we don't there's any time
because you know Lord King will be
designating things there
of course it is look you know here's
betting you that gaming realness on the
IOP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need here so let's get
right into as far as what the Lord's
been playing this week so Lord addict
what have you been touching this week
let me guess
halo was to played mr. shifty and that's
pretty much about all why I'm so mad
that you actually I paid I play now for
male player hey Lords to this morning
but shift nice how you liking mr. shifty
so far I beat it
alright it wasn't fun as it was a good
game cool cool cool no doubt and of
course morsov what have you been
touching this week so this week I've
been playing a little more Far Cry 3
getting a little further than that
um and then I played some Tacoma some
Edith Finch so that's what I've been
getting into and then looking forward to
hell blade next week
nice help lady that's a big one and of
course Lord King what have you been
touching this week I've been inside our
xbox arcade tearing it up I say no it's
like you know there's a game pass and
I've been playing all the metal slugs
and I found out that inside of me is
this weird passion to play a bunch of
Neo Geo stuff and I didn't know metal
slugs xx it's fantastic mmm this week I
could be touching it's been uh been a
grafter gonna touch about on our topic
later but I actually I got to finish eat
it Finch and I will talk about that no
loss table has a lot to say about that
and then um what else has been a lot I
did The Walking Dead basically this week
is this month is hash tag killed the
backlog because I we know that destiny 2
is coming so I'm just going through all
the games in my backlog and um basically
I still got a lot of the telltale stuff
to knock out but um I've done that that
Edith Finch and I'm still start a little
titanfall 2 so I was pretty much my week
as far as a gaming so before we get into
the topics we got last week's were off
before we go for adequate ear to the
talk
I know that you're talking about making
a look of Otsu a mod you want me to tell
you how to do it real quick oh I'm sure
I mean if you can know jump in you just
go to his name in the chat so just
getting it linked to the right sounds
good
I'll give carbide superpower but are we
gonna do the last week's poll results
there in the people have spoken the
winner at 61 percent wrong of the is it
unacceptable for a first-person shooter
to be thirty frames per second in 2017
beyond is the fun game group so all is
right in the world fun games over free
as most important so the group who
actually finished second has demanded
sixty frames being mandatory they
finished at 39% so it's my almost a
60/40 split and the people have spoken I
want to thank all 120 plus for
participate in the poll and I just want
to bring to the Lords what do we think
about this they spoke again I'm always
for a fun game above you know resolution
and framerate obviously those things
help and if they're super tight it makes
the experience that much tighter but
again if the game is enjoyable and none
of those technical things get in the way
then you know it is what it is whatever
whatever the developer felt is best for
the game
no that was it run smooth well I was in
the gameplay group I was actually
surprised that I was I was concerned
though the game isn't feel this way so
that's good to see that was good to see
even though I said I won't play Tekken 7
or 720 you know I don't want to keep
buying all these case until my xbox xx
experience so let's get into these
topics for the round tables alarm start
off with Lord King I know there's a lot
of rumors in the streets about this PS 5
so I'm gonna hand this off to you what's
been going over the psi was this talk
okay so the
no broke this week that the PS 5 is
they're trying to push this thing for an
announcement in 2018 probably a release
in 2019 I thought that the further along
would probably be like 2020 as far as
what they're trying to say for this
system and it seems like Sony is drunk
off of power and they and and I think
this is a bad president I thought they
would look at Nintendo and see how
Nintendo has done a lot of that stuff
underpowered sony wants to control the
narrative as they're the strongest
machine because you notice with the pro
they wanted to push that further out
there to you know to extend a reach even
though the regular PlayStation was
stronger than the regular Xbox but I'm
pretty sure that they got a little
insiders and they heard about the the
new Xbox that was coming and the Xbox s
that was doing 4k streaming and 4k video
and they said okay well we'll push the
power aspect of it and that's how we got
the pro well now the X is coming out and
you know for however time that lasts the
Xbox would be the most powerful console
on the market and then PlayStation 5
will come but as owners of a PlayStation
4 Pro and I have not really seen the
benefit from it my thing is what is the
rush to push this five out the door and
you haven't even maximized your pro mmm
interested yeah they're talking about a
[Laughter]
k8k will be will be pushing it everyone
was to jump in on this one sony stupid
enough to do it oh that's alright I
think they're just letting I mean Sean
Layton made it clear that you're not
gonna see a PlayStation 5 for some time
so I mean I'm looking at maybe an
announcement in 2018 earliest is fall
2019 earliest and and I mean and I
really mean that
early honestly I see it sometime 2020 if
they really want to make a generation of
the leap you know use rise and chips but
again they are content to let the
fanboys go to war for them and start
talking this stuff because it just by
the PS 5 being in a conversation you're
taking you're taking heat away from the
X you're taking you're taking people
looking from BX you're just taking the
conversation away from me as long as
people are talking about something
different something better it keeps away
from what's coming out now so and
they're more than happy to let that
happen even if it doesn't come out of
their own mouth I think if anything I
don't think there's another console
coming out to maybe 20 to maybe even 23
because I feel like I felt like a lot of
people or you know are under estimating
this is the what the Pro I think that
they would drop the original Xbox one
and the original PlayStation before they
brought something out in two more years
now what do you say to this Lord addict
and also no song to the people who I
mean obviously I do agree with you guys
I mean they are in a dominant position
there's really no rush for them to jump
out but at the same time when we did say
that these were the same guys that did
put out the ps4 Pro a lot of people
thought there was no need for the we
might see it we might see a slimmer Pro
I think the fact that you know they had
to add another taco layer on there they
had to add another layer on the ps4 to
make the Pro and the X's is smaller than
the slim I think that might really
irritate them a little bit mmm I mean
this is a good one looking I mean
because not only do we got that going on
then they spoke to I believe was at the
Gran Turismo developer
and the vibe that I got from him was
they were talking like they're gonna
future-proof their idols to the point
where at least the Gran Turismo series
for that they're talking 8k on this time
so I'm like okay now are they thinking
mid generation refresh are they thinking
you know obviously we've heard we've
heard different rules of thought I think
Michael Pachter he put something out
there in the reference that he's
thinking kind of like another mid
generation refresh not a full-grown
generation leap but then they've already
done that with the ps4 pearl so what are
the lowest think about that as far as a
kiss
that's what I thought I thought that
being that we were doing this mid
generation refresh stuff that that would
be the the pattern that they'll be doing
so you say like I think Xbox in 2019
we'll be talking about the index system
and the PlayStation would be dropping
their next system by 2019
so you get a drop and then you get a
type of thing that's why I think that
there was going to be doing like
leapfrog get each other back and forth
now shout the loss eyes back and low
ain't going to chat they're basically
saying it you know ps4 sales a peak they
think and it's coming 20/20 at delay
latest so what what do we think
you know people say maybe knock five
years down what if we had to gun your
head for the Lord's the roundtable if we
have to put a year that we think this
thing is coming what year I think if
anything the earliest is 21 I think 2012
OC and announced at 2020 and maybe it
come out in 21 or do like I just don't
see 18 19 20 those three years like
something might get announced but I
don't see them actually coming out those
three years because then what was the
point in the mid fresh why didn't you
just you know right you know it they
keep pushing the 4k narrative is just
like there's no point in going above
this right now people then saying a K
for K is not even a thing right now it's
it's so a K oh yeah yeah let's go with a
K set up the love Megatron in the chat
he's saying 2020 as well and I meant
2019 Louis ah see you want to jump in
and I want to throw something this
- though so quickly on that i think i
think it will be earlier something like
a 2019 2020 and i say this reason yeah
and i say this reason they're not gonna
let xbox hold that most powerful console
narrative long they don't want to do
that so and you leave you let xbox hold
that narrative for the next three I
think they've already reversed that
train like you know they used to be
about the power but not they promote we
got the best games like I think you
think they care about the power
narrative anymore because they giving up
the games to compete with the power
right so that's it Nick SIA III Xbox
drops of Megaton bomb of exclusive stuff
for PC and Xbox then what happens then
they're gonna say we have true
exclusives like they did last year
remember with all these years with all
these years I say they say they let xbox
have a narrative for three years when no
stuff to go in three years the price of
the X keeps dropping and dropping
dropping so you're looking at a more
powerful console that by the end of that
three-year period could probably be $250
you know it's a tough sell at that point
to keep saying well but you know we have
all these games and that X are gonna be
a tough sell regardless mmm but I mean
you don't know they are because
obviously they win the early stages of
the 4k adoption rate you know that kind
of thing but I guess my question are
happy you saw specifically your point
was that like what do you say to the
from let's say let's take a look at from
a Sony side where it's like you know
Microsoft came out the gate you know
they've been pumping the the you know
Scorpio narrative for about a year right
it's finally here and now obviously you
know it is the more powerful system you
can't dispute that but at the same time
there's also things like okay you're
they're doing check according to all
they're doing 30 frames per second - so
you don't think that maybe Sony may have
the stand point we kind of wait it out
because you know they're not as dominant
as we would like thought they work out
maybe they were waiting to see how
much more powerful it was maybe they
think into themselves they can kind of
stand pat you think that maybe you know
I think that can be an option and I
think we'll see that with over the next
the course of the next year and we'll
see how these games compared to each
other and the world that we're talking a
little bit about Killing Floor 2 and and
how that would not be all that different
at least to perceptible at least
perceptively different on the X as it is
on a ps4 probe mom so you know already
people talking about how the X is
hamstrung that it's not going to be able
to do all these things that it claims is
able to do so it's gonna depend how that
plays out over the next year and how
many of these games that are on both
systems these third-party games what the
X can do that if it's significantly
significantly different than what the
pro is doing if it's not then they might
be able to hold Pat is it I think when
it comes down to it like you know Sony's
came out open multiple times and said
like we saw it last Jim I mean what you
it's in relevant to have more power when
the third-party devs down they downpour
than up port they don't upwards and down
port and you know they they not made it
they have made it easier that that's
that's what their trump card was is
we're gonna make it easy it wort to the
Xbox 1x but when it comes down to it
like you know regardless what some
people like to think having the bigger
market share matters these third party
people don't want to mess with the
bigger market share absolutely so when
it comes to that perspective you know
the third parties are gonna you know
they're not gonna come openly out and
say it but I wouldn't be surprised that
there's some you know backdoor
you know Dylan going all in saying yo
you can't have the better but obviously
you got version you got like shadow war
you know games that are really hooking
up with the Xbox those are gonna see
benefits right the part that really you
know you'll see huge significant
increases first party you know it
wouldn't matter what the third parties
are doing if Microsoft was dropping hit
after hit that looked phenomenal that
showed this is what the power of the X
does but they're shown crackdown in the
opening day like you know we don't
Microsoft rest
that's one of those people that they
want to keep their you know their cars
to close the chest they could show
something a Gamescom
that's not crackdown that blows people
away and they could show something next
year at e3 that blows people away but
the community is not that you know
perception of look in the future kind of
mindset gamers aren't very impatient you
show them what's coming up now or you
don't show them at all I mean once
that's generation that's generation you
know attention span is so short she
approach that that Sony takes like look
will will tell you all of our cards it
will let the competition know all of our
cards because we're pretty sure they
have nothing for them right now well
that's been Sony tech forever they'll
tell you their cause but the games will
come out for the next 20 years
I completely agree I kind of think that
you know one of the biggest reasons they
want to do it is because the whole
fiasco with with you know fable legends
and scale Bell but when right your point
where you know being gun-shy slowly rely
on Indies to sell an e3 that you know
maybe you should announce one to two
games that's two or three years old yeah
that's a good point because I seem to
come a lot attic in reference to film
maybe being gun-shy after the scalebound
fiasco things of that nature and not
wanting it because I mean the vibe I've
got I had from him is that there's still
more to be shown that they still even
held back from this III and they're not
all exclusives that they do know I'm
gonna give it at the Lord King as your
top and I want you there ice to sting
off his flowers the developer for Gran
Turismo the reason why he said 8k
because by the time his game comes out
but that's not the real one these guys
in these games for so long and Forza has
been keeping a steady stream of giving
you their good butter so I'm not
you know really were they literally
listening to whatever he's saying this
guy is really saying he just told you
the release date for that gran turismo
he told you when a K is viable that's it
is coming out a couple days ago they
said that on Sony kind of made a
statement the same the last of us do is
then even full production yet so that's
not coming out so at least 20 exactly so
we you know we kind of wrap this whole
thing up
III honestly think and this this is just
my thought though by the time the
PlayStation 5 actually comes out I say
2020 I really believe 2020 2020 okay all
right
I believe we probably might have an Xbox
x+ it's already in the right - Jes
Gordon lean those guys shout out the ran
and those dudes of Xbox do this develop
develop I mean the moment the whole name
and everything about five years correct
my plus two it though it's just an easy
fix just swap out the jag well I'm
putting a rising and do a scalability of
factor to it
that's my yes because if if everything
that I've been hearing and every
developer has been saying you know you
know get you have something that you
know total company line but anybody
that's come out and said anything
against the Xbox X before it even hit
the streets is hamstrung by the CPU yeah
and I've been seeing a lot of rise in um
chipsets and right now they update their
they doing they like the hype or
thrasher edition something like that and
I just saw him digitally the digital
foundry um
if they're doing that and they're
pushing that extreme or CPU then that
means the price on the value price CPU
is dropping and that's more powerful
than a Jaguar that would alleviate a lot
of the hamstrings on the X so I honestly
think that's a quick fix and an amid
refresh like you know so they like to do
like if you know you up
in your phone and they update the
chipset inside this thing is kind of
going away a phone where we're gonna get
these these mid gen refresh is kind of
from from both sides is what you're
saying you don't see it pretty much
going the route of a full out of green
so I think every four years we're gonna
get a refresh to the console so you
agree with with Lord back there no
they're great on this one I think if we
get an adoption rate that is high enough
then they can start a subscription type
of thing like you have with your phones
will you pay your phones off on a
monthly basis and they do that with
consoles that our refresh rate on
systems will be a whole lot faster will
be within a two year time period I
believe and it will update the innards
inside of the the consoles a whole lot
faster if we can get to a hundred
million type of a subscription rate
thing that they can offset and subsidize
the cost and I don't know why we haven't
drifted closer to that I think these are
the first steps going towards that but I
think that's in our near future and
it'll be more beneficial for us I always
thought that them Microsoft was gonna
make some kind of deal with Comcast or
something and convert at the original
Xbox ones into digital converters and
we're and have and uh sell them to
Comcast and Comcast can rent them to
their customers you know by doing like
the TV phase when they won yes they came
up the box with that that would be our
goal was so in on when this damn game
will even try Gran Turismo could come
out tomorrow and I wouldn't care the
killing Felicity visit of what are we
gonna cause Xbox kind of did do that
towards the end of the 360 generation
with the final revision of the 360 the
II I believe they you bought it with
like I
if you paid for two years of Xbox Live
service or whatever you got the console
for free so they did kind of dip their
toe in that a little bit to see how it
would react
I don't think doing it at the end of the
generation was probably the best thing
because I chose nothing at the beginning
yeah exactly a lot of class old in terms
of sales so you're not really getting a
clear picture of how interested people
are in it right I think yeah I don't
think it's necessarily a bad idea you
know what you for your services
I think the biggest thing Microsoft
needs to work on right now is making
sure these these these third-party JRPGs
come to the Xbox because that's what's
killing we go get into that that's that
it's coming out it's coming up next but
real quick sorry yeah also made me Tommy
and let's be honest I mean hardware
sales are down you know formalism should
be speaking on the Microsoft side and um
you know one thing is you know gay
services like game paths you know things
that they're trying to promote this may
be that way you know and when we got to
see when the Xbox one extra do they like
say hey here's three months the game
past and start really focusing on that
that's kind of like a mission statement
is where they want to go as far as the
hallway not that you know it's almost
secondary but you you're carrying the
subscription with you throughout all
platforms kind of thing you know so we
shall see so anyway if that's what the
Lord's got we're gonna move on you know
Lord had actually had me excited about
my next topic so we're gonna talk about
I'm gonna set this thing off for a round
table as far as a dragons quest and the
um tremendous success in Japan on the
3ds and the and the ps4 and just over
like least couple of two like two or
three days in two or three days both of
them far as the ps4 Nintendo 3ds
versions of Dragon Quest 11 sold a
combined over 2 million copies at retail
so to put it in perspective you know the
switch with the Wii U and the switch
versions of Legend of Zelda Breton Wow
so 230 thousand copies during the first
three days out and then splatoon which
is actually really huge in Japan they
estimate about six hundred and seventy
in its first three days out so to see
that surpass all these games include
even I think Pokemon Sun and Moon which
I believe in their first three days sold
over
two million but a little under so what
the brain is to the roundtable you know
we know a switch version is on the way
for the rest into 2018 but I wanted to
talk about success of this game and also
the resurgence of JRPGs what are the
lowest think about it do we think it's a
Japan with a lot attic I know you want
to talk about it so go for it when it
comes to it you put someone in a room
and stall them for a few months you know
when you do give them food they're going
get it so Stephen JRPG stop this I even
JRPG styled it's the whole switch in
general you star someone long enough
they're going buy it when you give it to
them
shut up the Lord echo and the chase is
over three million you are correct link
I was giving you a little bit older
numbers in the first three days which
you're correct they've been releasing
minor armed JRPGs out there they haven't
been giving it to us like we haven't
received this yet so those numbers I
think would be greater if they did a
worldwide release but that's you know a
localization and all that other stuff I
understand that but Final Fantasy is the
only thing that can rival a dragon's
quest and that franchise is so loved and
beloved so those numbers really don't
shock me at all because you know the
systems is out there they can sell those
systems so it was just all about filling
a void for those gamers and like Lord
addict said you feed them they will show
up and it will eat testament to a good
game let me ask you this looking at it I
guess I'm just so surprised because you
know obviously is Japan you know the
markets different i know dragon runs
well I've never played dragons game so
let's get that right out alright I just
sorted game your style looks beautiful
it seems like a turn-based original
style JRPG that I've grown up there
right so I'm absolutely loving that
whole thing so I'm alright let me see
what the hype is but I guess I was
surprised it just destroyed sell them
and I'm saying is you got a look at the
the install base now people people
actually I mean if you added up all of
Zelda but how am i how much do they so
is launched sure they're also at easy
thing now splatoon is bigger than jet
Zelda
right in Japan the tone is way bigger
and the fact this will just came in
Japan in Japan the tool to say the
install base is four times the size it
was when all things are leveled you drop
splatoon and Dragon's quest kind of came
out comics a name it can't compete
without them but not yeah tone - is the
multiplayer game that's the game playing
with with your friends where's the
Dragon Quest is more of a single-player
experience and for it to me to smash
draggable toon like that like that was
crazy to me people's been looking for
that game I'm looking for that game Ivan
by these little Dragon Quest things that
they got that you play like um those uh
what are those games that we play uh law
sovereign um dynasty warriors they yeah
they've been dropping those and I've
been eating them up I brought it from my
playstation pro uh I was getting this
but it's switch to tell us all the
problems that it was having so yeah I
want the real game and it is felt like
that when it gets here you're gonna you
gonna be surprised with the numbers in
the States for that game Dragon Quest
will probably do a million in the states
often yeah when it comes to Japan I mean
Dragon Quest and Pokemon are king that's
that's just it and that that's king over
Mario that's king over Zelda I'm Manny
and and the funny thing is like when you
talk about splatoon yes but soon you
definitely have more you have more
switches in the wild now than when Zelda
came out so obviously but we can't also
underestimate the popularity of that
game period in Japan splatoon is a
movement in Japan I mean it like they it
really is something
definitely won't do that kind of numbers
in the States yeah but look like Japan
embraces it's it's it's country brand
like there's a Laura Goku stands down
there like the entire Japan especially
Tokyo is filled with its brand that was
made there you can't go anywhere about
seeing Naruto in Japan it's true there's
true I mean it's just like I said I
guess like you said loss thought it
really surprised me because I didn't
realize the power of that game I mean
that game over there is just monstrous
it's a beast and like I said I was I was
completely blown away so I guess the
next question is you know the laws in
reference to this you know do we think
there's a slight resurgence in JRPGs
obviously we know persona 5 came out
here did pretty did pretty well for
PlayStation I'm assuming and then um you
know we have a couple other big JRPGs
now coming on the way obviously we did
here I believe the developer for Dragon
Quest this guy Rory he said it's coming
to the west they have a big announcement
in fall of 2017 about when it comes to
the west and the big rumor is it's
coming to the switch so yeah you know
what do we feel about JRPGs or do we
feel they're making a comeback can they
succeed out here in the West now this is
the problem I love blue dragon for Xbox
I love the miss Walker games and fresh
box and the thing is with JRPGs you have
to build them you know Dragon Quest 1
didn't start off selling off millions
and millions of copies like that you
have to build them you have to hold on
to that franchise and you have to walk
it through the shadows and get it to the
sunlight and if you give up on these
titles early you lose so of course
Dragon Quest and Final Fantasies these
names that we know
the West outlaw only geography that
matters is fallout that's what's going
on anchorman maybe me you play different
fallouts
we need to fight for our RPGs that we
have well you know Microsoft has a
catalog other RPGs have soft you know
it's it's it's arguable that Microsoft's
got some of the best geography Jesus
came out in the past ten years exactly
but if they don't push him if they don't
say yo we willing to take this loss we
willing to go forward and make these
games because these games are coming out
both the only names that you're gonna
hear Dragon Quest final fantasy dragon
quest and it was a big move for for
Microsoft to score those marketing
rights for Final Fantasy 15 but yes you
gotta go more than that yeah it's always
a market for JRPG sorry Lord addict it's
always a market there that's one of the
reasons that Microsoft is getting
stomped this year is because you know if
you look at it from a perspective of
first party titles Sony's drug horizon
zero dawn that's all but if you look at
if you would know nope if you thought I
was about to get to that if you looked
okay the exclusive stuff that they've
gotten from second parties they could
easily have came to my us to Microsoft's
platform right everything else is is
legit we could go either way
there yes the question game show
Microsoft's gonna announce near are
moderate come into Xbox
mmm now let me ask you this question
when I could you make an interesting
point this is what I want to get go out
with JRPGs and this also goes in
conjunction with something Lord King
said a couple of top its back you know
is it one of those things that you know
obviously we know Xbox does not have a
great relationship over its bed we
clearly know this is an issue and
obviously there's a huge fan base that
wants to JRPG so do we still as Lord
King would say you know keep going over
there
tracking
over there with your face maybe the
results we want before still hoping to
get these titles or you just as
Microsoft just you know pitched at 10:00
just say hey they're never going to
release these titles for us they never
you know they're never gonna really
conform to us so why bother like what
what do you say that all I'm saying is
it's like the whole Xbox play anything
where you know they might not sell the
greatest on Xbox but it's perception you
have Microsoft uh having four less
exclusives this year because they don't
have they don't have near they don't
have no uh they don't have Noah they
don't have persona 5 and when you see
some of these games going to switch who
do you know it's Microsoft it's not the
other equations it's Microsoft how is I
am setsuna not on Xbox how is the sequel
not on Xbox how is anything you know
anything Dragon Quest related not on
Xbox and don't say it's Square Enix
because we've had exclusive stuff Square
Enix spelling is Microsoft tell them
Lucy I mean you know Tokyo game shows up
and strategy on how to counter that
right after it's like I said I said this
from the start I said you can't go to
big unless they went out and wrote
blight checks to get big big stuff it's
kind of the like you boy that's what he
used to do back there there's two
approaches you can make with it one you
got and get a really really big one it's
gonna cost you a lot of money but
something or you you introduced little
or titles to the front and that's what
they're doing they're introducing little
more titles to build that fanbase up so
they can actually do that but I don't
think that's enough you need to go to
miss Walker you need to be you need to
make another Lost Odyssey because that's
the only brand that Microsoft has in
JRPGs that could actually make them
money but you know they
they got to reach out and they gotta pay
they just have to know stop get out of
this yeah I mean obviously I think I
think the resurgence of this and the
interest in this is its kind of twofold
first thing is the fact that Japanese
games in general are doing I've seen the
resurgence over here and are and are
more kind of in the public eye when you
talk about the return of Resident Evil
and how successful that has been with
Neal and with new automata even though
these games on xbox they've proven that
the US audience watched these Japanese
games so the automata looks littered I'm
sorry
it is fantastic it is a Xbox gamer we
ain't gonna get that right now it's
ridiculous
yes and it's the perception it's the
perception that the Xbox gamer doesn't
want that type of game and that is
something that that Microsoft has to
they have to work towards changing that
and by doing it like you said they'd
have to back up the truck and bring a
big one over it's gonna cost them money
but at least with that they show they
dedicated to that let me quit too
because I also felt that the Dragon Ball
Z thing was a good look dude and I said
you know what that's the kind of stuff
they have to do but you know just get
the marketing do like if that would have
came out there and that was an exclusive
that would have been big listen at the
at the end of the day I probably would
you looking you know it probably could
probably really tough for them to get it
completely school so I don't know what
they'd have to do to get that they have
two bikes
yeah it was huge it was I was listening
to an interview with at fries talking
about this stuff about what they had to
do when they went to Japan initially and
when they initially went to talk about
the lg Xbox and how honestly like they
were taking these execs out to dinner
spending
on wooing these guys and what everybody
saw whatever this is Oh gx4000 gee okay
okay
shame is blackly like all of these guys
oh gee
and the thing about it is that they
needed to do that to get those initial
those initial Japanese games period onto
the Xbox I feel Toby it's not like that
absolutely you know I know a lot of
people don't really have this light in a
consideration but Microsoft's an
American brand and let's be real here
that majority of the world does not like
America there's only Japan you know
obviously there's gonna be smashing
especially Japan because let me let me
flip it though alone attic in Japan we
do tend to come over there with these
big bulky boxes to try to force on them
like they do at the same time I think
the reason that American brand doesn't
so I think it's more than just games I
think I think it's politics I think it's
a lot more than that it's it's it's a
relationship we've had with in the past
we don't even let them the right to bear
are like not bear arms but it's a simple
an army we literally took that right
from them that's why our our Air Force
is over there saying I think it's more
than just games that the reason
Microsoft you're making about
acquaintances is it could be definitely
you know something Mike Ibarra makes me
anyway Phil Phil I trust I'm gonna give
you the way that you get this Japanese
RPG thing cracking and it's gonna be
stateside you go over there and you go
to the schools and you poach you poach
these developers that are in these
schools and then you know that's swing
you bring them over here yo you get your
development houses over there in Silicon
Valley you bring them over
and then also you go to these game
communities and you get them instead of
just saying okay here's these indie kits
and y'all do this no no you actually
make them employees you actually
cultivate these guys you don't put that
stuff in a preview program that
everybody get a chance to touch it up
early you don't do that stuff you
cultivate these guys and when these
games come to fruition you put them in
game past this pushes your game past and
make sure these developers get paid but
you make sure that their games are RPGs
you stock that game pass up with RPGs
and I'm telling you it's going to sell
right now you have a lot of quick action
arcade games in there and people are
looking at it and say well it's not too
much stuff in there for me
you gotta start filling in those fillers
you fill them in which your developers
because our development houses are
really empty I mean can you really say
how many other developers there is
besides are the for the team and it
gives a war team and a low team all the
teams the cupboard is bare the cupboard
is bare fact I mean in the fact of the
matter is they're in the business of
making money and that's how we get into
it you know the whole thing that I hate
which is you know the Big Mac loss you
know so I did it I don't want to say
mate JRPGs Microsoft should not make
JRPGs you do not expect an American
company to make a JRPG but I hope I
don't expect the third party ones to
show up on the console what I'm saying
you could have an American company make
it if you get the culture right you
basically saying is you want to stop
poaching some talent over there and get
them you know in right I don't think
it's party studios I don't think that's
an option they can take for the most
part you know
Japan's really loyal to Japan like in
very traditional I love fastback
synergize it's a tough one man it's it's
tough when the other the other option I
know we going left with this I'm gonna
wrap it up soon
the other option to which I see what
they're doing if you look at Greenberg
if you look at you know what's going on
you see them really trying to make that
push in China so also you know that
could be another
route as far as say hey we may take the
El in Japan but at least get our feet
over here as far as another territory at
four is another region right now they
can do stuff yeah they're out there
pretty hard so you know that's another
thing but I know we're going left good
tablet for JRPGs and Dragon know they're
gonna have to if they don't want to
build a uh they are doing it that you
know there's a few good games that they
showed a three that's Japanese or
teleport show is coming out look it
seriously I don't want to do something
like that you know continue this thing
they're gonna have they're gonna have to
buy an exclusive that's gonna cost a lot
of money
look what would have happened if Final
Fantasy 15 would have been an exclusive
sure would have cost them a lot of money
but you would had a huge surge of people
they have been waiting for that game for
15 years that would have bought an Xbox
for that one game I don't think so I
don't think would have been pushed back
man they don't like seven eight million
on the PlayStation you mean to see them
seven eight million people will wait
over there for it I'm just saying I
don't think it would it would ever
happen period but this one this besides
seven this Final Fantasy was arguably
the most hyped Final Fantasy ever made
absolutely absolutely because of that
reason because of that reason they would
have seen it as such a betrayal 1 Square
Enix this far I don't see it man I don't
see you would have more you would have
more numbers just not numbers like that
not even close but let's wrap this thing
cuz I know we go on knowing about JRPGs
yeah are we gonna get this thing going
over the lowest song I want to talk
about uh eat it Finch and walking
simulators what's going on in this this
world right now boss uh yeah so we
talked about two walking simulators in
particular and I and then anybody who
sees the name walking simulator as a
pejorative that's not it we I love
walking simulators so if I just like you
the net
I don't this is for the old man in the
group the people here I know young fun
you play a lot of them we go get into
this the king of what exhibit laters
we're gonna get it we don't get into
that - we're gonna get into that so
basically what remains to be this Finch
is a game that came out earlier on
PlayStation and PC and and over the last
couple weeks has made his way over to
Xbox and also this past week fulbright
released their follow-up to gone home to
coma so what I wanted to talk about was
these these type of games walking
simulator type games where it's like a
Nadder narrative story driven sort of
first-person games and do we like them
do we dislike them what about them do we
like and also in in in and now seeing
these big announcements that telltale is
made with their games and what's coming
out over the course of the next year
especially with Batman coming out next
year on a weird how I was doing that
they don't normally do that yeah they
have like their own Nintendo Direct when
it came to like they just dropping vinyl
normally announced games so far out like
yeah they usually announce the first
episode three or four months before it
comes out yeah
so might what I want to talk about is
how do these two type of games compare a
telltale game and what is traditionally
called a walking simulator and what do
we like about each one and don't don't
like about each one because there's
plenty of the kind of dissect there
because they approach they approach the
genre very differently
definitely definitely I want to jump in
on this on both sides when I saw your
topic before to the table forehand I was
very excited cuz I actually touch Edith
Finch this week and shout out to
basement radio arcade shout out to um
Randall throwing those guys I mean those
and actually shot the motor anchorman
because I was looking at Twitter
and I'm seeing everyone going crazy
about this damn eateth fish and I'm like
what is the deal with this like I gotta
see what it is I picked it up this week
added it to the backlog and I started it
and again I'm gonna do give you the
non-spoiler because I know I don't
believe a lot King what I haven't
touched yet no but um basically it does
fall in that realm of walking simulator
however it's kind of um kind of like
short story experiences and the best
thing I can tell you is this thing is
disturbing you know some people have
even said like emotionally at the end of
some of these stories and things that
you find out you know that it has an
affecting you all I will say is
something that you need to experience
it's really done beautifully that the
story some of them are so uniquely
crafted and done in a way that they put
you in the mind of someone else and um I
just thought it was it was cool now I'm
hearing people screaming out game of the
Year eyeing on there but it's it's such
a unique title and it's so different in
the traditional way that a walking
SimCorp unquote will be done that is
worth a pick up it's worth that 20 or
whatever it is right now on Xbox Live I
believe you just came out there so check
it out you know as far as the overall
question we lost Ava's saying I'm a huge
fan of you know I grew up Imogene so I
grew up in the days when you went to the
library you picked up a book called
choose your own adventure and through
your own adventure you know you if you
disagree with so you agreed with choice
B you turn to page 55 you didn't you
turn the page like that's the stuff I
grew up on
so anything that involves heavy
narratives that involves tough choices
and what I love about the telltale stuff
is that there's a time there's that time
limit where it's like you've got to make
it now you know I just you know walk I
finished Walking Dead new frontier this
week there was about four choices that
really I wrestled with that really
messed me up mentally then this the way
that was done through flashbacks and
stuff like that so again I love the
genre
long to people who like more than men
who don't like it you know yes I will
say that telltale sometimes I think is
cash you need a little extra big they do
a lot of them but in their defense for
the most part the majority are really
done well and um you know I really like
stuff like that life is strange is
another one you know a good spin on it
really emotional deep personal life
issues and stuff like that I would
recommend you guys take a look at that
so I'm a family I hope it doesn't go
away
I know it's being monetized a bit heavy
right now but games like eat a cinch to
me show why I love the genre so much I
think when you when you look at Edith's
fitments and when you look at Tacoma
that is a certain type of quote-unquote
walking simulator whereas the telltale
games are very different
honestly I'm what I was saying like the
total games is story narrative you know
like it's like a book that you're going
to do comic panels almost like and it
you're just kind of living out the story
that they want you to see um and they
given you a little bit of agency and you
know in terms of like the QTEs and stuff
like that and decisions you make but at
the end you ultimately reach the same
conclusion now when you're looking when
you look at Tacoma and when you look at
um Edith Finch you do reach ultimately
the same conclusion but they give you
more agency within the world to walk
around and touch things and experience
things kind of out of order sometimes
whereas your experience is your own and
it's not as directed as a tell tale
experience um and that's what that's
what I love about these type of games
because they throw you in there they're
always in first-person right so you kind
of take on the agency of whatever of
that that character you're not yourself
and you're not watching or you're not
watching a third person character and
you're walking around the world and
you're able to touch this and look at
this a look at a room they they have I
do an excellent job of creating time and
place in these stories where you feel
kind of engrossed in it um whereas a
telltale game you're engrossed in the
store
and the characters because you know
those characters a lot of telltale games
now - they're based on their they're
based on like third Gardens right their
licenses so they're not gonna you're not
gonna ever play a game like that in
first person because you're not going to
see the license character it's not gonna
happen right with Tacoma and Edith Finch
and something like Firewatch and gone
home these things they they create
atmosphere by throwing you into the
middle of something and you don't know
what's going on and it's on you to kind
of unravel it but you unraveling it by
kind of your your habit a ting that that
space really you're in it whether it's
the music whether it's the graphics how
you walk around the world it kind of
it's very engrossing just to compare it
quickly to um at this past weekend I
want this past week I want to see
dunkirk mom and I saw it and I saw it in
70 millimeter IMAX Dolby Atmos around
free man berries talk sorry
comparison yeah I made the comparison
because what Dunkirk does that a lot of
war movies don't do it doesn't rely like
if you look at a Saving Private Ryan or
you look at a um Apocalypse Now
something like that those have very huge
booming orchestral kind of scores and
stuff like that and there and I get a
huge set pieces now Dunkirk as those
same huge set pieces but what they do
with music and sound is that it's not
you don't have this big orchestral score
what you have is like silences coupled
with like kind of unnerving sound
effects like like the movie there's like
a ticking clock always in the background
and you know something bad is gonna
happen or like when you see all these
soldiers on a beach and and these are
the German bombers come down you they
look up in the sky everything goes
silent you don't see anything except the
soldier looking up in the sky and as the
Bombers get closer and closer to bombing
them on the beach then you start hearing
this like screaming wail of the lonely
of the oh bombers right before they drop
the bombs on you and
that does is it serves to kind of engulf
you in the experiments right rather than
you listening to like this this you know
John Williams score in the background or
whatnot it's that's what these do so
well is that they allow you to inhabit
this world in a fantastic to me and then
their great palate cleansers like if
you're playing war cry three and you
want to go to jump something up that's a
little more slow and pace
these games are perfect for that
absolutely Lord King what adequate
events feel about these because I saw my
timeline blowing up with this sort on
YouTube oh oh no as a full release is a
real game yeah you know I check is a
full release is a real game I was a real
boy alright now no Pinocchio crap like
he ever build the game Oh
so I said okay these guys have been
saying good things about it but I'm
still apprehensive about it so now that
you gave me basically the walkthrough of
it you know without the spoilers I love
tell tales for that whole thing look I'm
you know was saying like if you don't
agree with this and you want to drink
the poison go to pay something I say
wolf among us is probably their best
thing I ever got the Batman get the
Batman sorry guys I'm getting Batman but
yeah look fantastic with a different
take on Batman um I'm gonna give this
game a shot because what you're saying
it's in that vein but not as structured
and restrictive as the telltale games
because regardless to what you know you
can choose whatever you want in telltale
games like Lord sovereign said it's
absolutely getting to the same thing
yeah yeah you're not really walking
around the world and embracing in the
world and feeling things you go from one
step panel to the next you can touch a
couple of things here and there and then
ego aggresses the story so it's a little
bit more freedom from what I'm hearing
loss sovereign is what you're saying you
get more freedom in this yeah just
walking around the world yeah is it is
it like that stupid preview program game
long night now long dark is different
because that lasts more like parkour
survival you just gotta survive the
night watch your body temperature that's
actually more in the line of a game game
whereas this is more like you don't want
to spoil it but it's just twisted it is
linear but it allowed it allows you to
walk around the world and again like the
feeling you get from the world is your
own as you walk around you observe the
house you can go into rooms like and
there's clues about what happened in
that place just by if anyone wants to
know where my hate the genesis of my
hate for the pro sorry saw yes I know I
was gonna learn at because I want to
know why he just disdained it especially
when he plays all of the because if you
have a point of reference to say I
played them and they suck and I at least
yes I've looked at it didn't look like
something I would be interested in same
reason Firewatch mm-hmm so like Edith
Fitch and fire what you like not for you
I played fire watch and I just didn't
get me yeah I love fire watch actually -
have you played going home this type of
game and a game that kind of subverts
what you expect it to be and it's not
that he's going home I will say this too
important to us of and as far as like
affecting outcome what I do need to see
from telltale is that I need like you
say like in looking for mention this as
well like an even like you know what I'm
talking about I'm not gonna grab them
and play The Walking Dead Season one to
season two at this point
come on y'all but basically I want a
situation where those choices truly
change the entire narrative of the
sequel right so that in a sense that
you'd have to build up two different
games based on you know who survived and
who didn't as opposed to like a little
cameo by somebody here and that's it you
know you got good look I want some more
scenarios like life is strange in there
where you see what like what you choose
you know the okay and you know I can't
say they've never had it because I feel
like you know people tell me that you
know the because I still haven't
finished Game of Thrones but I've been
told the the choices in Game of Thrones
are real rough there's no doubt but like
again I'm gonna spoil something I'm
sorry to the chat if you guys haven't I
just played Walking Dead new frontier
right when you played the last Walking
Dead Season 2 in Clementine there was a
major choice at the end right
based on that major choice it you had to
pick who out of somebody you was rockin
with for a long time and somebody new
survived because those two would want to
kill each other right the choice you
made then ended with you with that
person who survived when walking
new frontier comes out I'm like there's
nothing of that like it's completely
it's the same thing from season 1 to
season 2 right it literally it relevants
the entire path all of that irrelevant
and then I actually watch the wet-on-wet
play because I guess I had some issue
important my save over whatever suddenly
all right if I imported my save what
would have happened with no surviving
character in literally Lord addict it
was a 10-minute flashback scene of the
person who with you and so survive and
then you get no context on what happens
to them for moving forward and I was
like really
they've got to fix that because ii mean
indeed what do the choice is really mean
right they're not making a whole new
game like that they got to do better
than that but then that would that will
facilitate them making two games on one
disk or you know because let's say one
guy picked this guy now you pick that
guy when you're buying the game both
scenarios are supposed to be on that
disc my way because exactly because when
you make the wrong decision in dragon
age like your real official cause and
effect I remembering I remember in the
first Dragon Age where they were talking
in Hell I wouldn't really paid attention
when I was saying I was but the same
time I wasn't really really Justin lying
what will might happen that I said the
wrong thing at home girl my team was
like I ain't down with that but I think
as long as they making as many games as
they are they're not going to do
anything that we've been here in forever
like the the the engine is janky its
it's choppy and they have
really done anything to rectify that yes
they keep making all these games for
them to get better and to improve the
formula they need to scale down a little
bit and I'm oh shut up shut up at youth
Finch no for at least doing it different
you know a different take on it and
definitely freaking me out there's some
parts that are somewhat alike something
you don't mean to laugh at deaf but some
people call it bad in that game like
this stupid for that but got a guy would
I definitely advise the Lord to check
that with personally some telltale games
mess some people were knowing me so much
I'm like I gotta get this kid like he
got a go never die like it's like what
am i doing if I can't even get someone
killed
what addict gonna pass this to you I
know a big point of contention has been
the switch in that online service so so
I was wanting to you know obviously they
have the $20 price tag 20 or 25 it
doesn't really matter at this point and
you know they got the the wack app
service to a point where you can only
talk to the people in a game chat but
not the enemy game chat then have
service where you can't host the party
the app service were if you're if you
know someone calls you you kicked out of
the app stash service where you know you
can't sit uh
if you leave the game you get kicked out
of the app you know I wanted and you
know I want to hear your guys's
perspective if $25 might be too much
would you guys pay $25 for this if they
cuz they are blocking multiplayer with
this multiplayer will be blocked with it
you have to have this to buy it to play
anything online well as of now right
yeah as of right now
according to like what like adding scene
with the fine print
multiplayer is free for now right but
until when the service officially goes
live according to the father-in-law
radix showed it to me and I was actually
surprised that I believe multiplayer is
behind that wall
so I guess when that goes live it gets
taken away from anyone who doesn't have
the service so I thought this was a good
topic that he brought up um I'm curious
what Lord Kings statement on this
because yet for me it's like look when I
taught debut we know damn well I'm not
doing it I'm not doing it I'm not as far
as I'm concerned they don't have an
online voice chat option when it comes
they don't have a voice chat option
so now just comes down to okay this is
part of T multiplayer service if that is
the case and this is part of the multi
player and if they take that away I
think they'll have a huge uproar I think
there's no way I think like I said it
would be a huge mistake because that
means right now people who are playing
Mario Kart right that goes live to play
[Laughter]
the blueprint honey savings even if
they're stuck with the whack party chat
to me what they have to do is say
okay one if this is we're gonna paint it
out let's be real here I got stuck with
the chat that though let's let's not act
like they're not incapable of doing it
at all at the same time they better one
add some type of messaging service
between people on the friends list
number two they gotta add some type of a
treatment system something some type of
trophy lesbian outlawed addict or
alcoholic coins call it medals whatever
you want to call it because that's
another thing that they don't have with
their their service like there's a lot
of people shopping or you know kid is
moving a lot of people that achievements
is a big deal there's people who want to
play the game and get that recognition
you know I'm saying for doing whatever
these accomplishments do and they don't
have my thing is if you're gonna pay
twenty dollars and you already got this
archaic system you know you need to add
a couple more features to do that then
philosophy from the beginners the same
philosophy that they have right now they
don't care what you think they have a
plan set in motion and then I'll put it
this way I have absolutely zero
confidence in them zero I know that
they're gonna charge you $25 you're not
gonna see the benefit I know that for a
fact
I had Nintendo Power no benefit okay you
got your power rewards and you can get
this but I got that you know how many
power was I
and I never got that glove shout-out to
trust me when I'm telling you this they
are the king of the bamboozle you open
arm they sure do know twenty-five
dollars for this if you don't pay by
this day you cut off from playing with
your friends it's not gonna happen
watch that day the negative backlash
they are no joke right now
but I've never seen all the major media
outlets say what a Nintendo it's not
just bloggers and us and podcasters and
media creators
these are the media saying what the hell
are you doing so the only hope I have is
that if history is how about remember
when they first announced the online
service off and they said that the
Virtual Console game is gonna be you
don't have it for the month and then
when the month had end it's gonna go you
go get it at a disc right and people are
like whoa whoa whoa why are you doing
that games of gold oh right right they
let you keep the game and then what you
call even said you know PSA and PS plus
they let you keep the game now once it
came out closer to launch they may
change that they said oh no we're gonna
give you the thing and now you keep it
so all I'm hoping is the launcher it
didn't want you but they did change they
all action they said they'd change the
policy but they didn't launch it right
no they've already changed the policy
already as it is before don't you know
this is how I feel about these guys
until it's in the wild can trust can
trust the word that they say now
everybody's been pissed off the Nintendo
hasn't done a show at e3
so long they have taken a joint to a
point where they are this overbearing
parent that knows the best for the child
no matter what we are the children okay
they don't care what we say you're not
eating that unless you eat your
vegetables twenty-five dollars up and
you can go outside with your friends
they're not going outside with your
friends unless you got your 25 dollars
playing my switch and I don't know how
long and I probably won't play it until
rabbits show up and then I probably
won't play it for a couple of months
until Mario's never get from me that
ain't happening just cause like you said
Nintendo's Nintendo
they are never ever gonna be me - never
they'll never do to them even if it's to
their detriment which it is they're
never gonna be me - why do you think you
have this big ass stupid splatoon like
now we have to go left no matter where
and again it's in a way it's a hubris
thing it's a hubris thing in a way out
of this like we're always different
we're always different and then we put
ourselves in a position where we're
different
but we're coming outlast now so then
people have all these expectations about
how we're supposed to follow suit with
what Xbox and PlayStation is doing and
they're like no no matter what it's not
happening that's why I firmly believe
you never go see any sort any sort of
achievements on yeah
you think they just go and left just cuz
problem would just snow stand that they
now they're involved in because of the
success i so i started i still stand
behind my just sell an Xbox Live card
with every so it's what about this y'all
what about they just make the deal with
discord or Skype and loud it happen to
be on the system is if they handed that
[ __ ] to set to Microsoft like make it
for us
that's legit Lee the only thing that's
gonna save that the thing is that it is
a little weird because again they showed
that they are willing to open up more
now it's done with ubisoft they've done
it with with putting their games onto
mobile with oh i do have a question for
you guys
do you think it's not necessarily like
you know me and Laura kognito are
talking about this I don't even think
it's that they don't want to do it I
just think that they don't have the
talent and they're too proud and to
Armstrong I think it's something that
Lord King said to IOPS ago
I think is these old exactly no more for
you and I think where was that young
dude they took over that's because if a
lot of stuff they're doing like wow they
allow third-party engines to that you
noted to be tested on a switch so for
easy portability I really feel it's an
internal regime
power struggle no this is for the kids
and we don't want anybody talking to
strangers and we don't let you talk Part
II chapter partager there's no logical
reason for them to have the system in
and is confusing and convoluted the way
that it's like they're purposely making
it difficult so that people don't talk
to each other oh then we'll actually go
and make that thing work isn't take the
Xbox one app copy to the team I put a
party system in it and they got
something people would pay $25 for an
event like a you know what what I want
this wish to do is actually updated UI
to work let's say Lord King David gets
all oh cool man I touched it on my
screen cuz I thought it looks like you
can do so I touch it on the screen his
profile pops up I say invites a party it
sends a ping to my phone and my phone
starts a party and sends a sense of an
invite to the party know is they have to
make the the app background though has
to be be able to be played in the
background I don't know why they thought
it was a bright idea to make this at
close for everything like wordy it's
over everything is so free and let's be
honest it's it's it's just this right
now is just a split to do an app let's
call it what it is right we can't use
this if I want to do Mario Kart right
can we watch them make an app for every
game it's like oh you want to play Mario
Kart I don't have that never say it will
never say this but in terms of the
hardware
maybe it's developed in such a way that
they can't do it because this when you
look at the regular UI on the switch
right you don't ever see two
applications open at the same time right
you open it and if you want to open
another
you're right you have to go the other
way it could be a multi tasking do I
think shout out the little aggravated he
said the tendo's of the power struggle
between Calvin and Jim Rice you all
right though they may not be able to
multitask with that you I I don't think
they have the talent to come up with to
make it around there I like Nintendo
seems like the kind of company that made
the way they've been act in the past ten
years worth they don't have the talent
to do it Bain asking for help this is
just what you get this is what I'm gonna
say on this right
this is London towards a lot of
sovereigns critics with these guys is
that they always want to go left my
opinion is they're always gonna go left
they're always gonna do their own thing
I've noticed this forever but they
could've went they could have gotten
Nvidia shield from Nvidia it wasn't
selling stick to controllers on the side
it would have been bigger and more
powerful boom no they had to go to
Nvidia listen we want a special Tegra oh
well give us the old Tegra and we wanted
this way we wanted hamstrung in a manner
that is gonna hurt this way just put
your face on it
run listen they would have been in such
a great position but no they went over
there to get Nvidia involved no we got
all hype about insidious down with these
guys and it's going down and let me give
you another thing remember y'all kept
saying that old because they let you be
soft run off with Mario rerio they did
that before they did that with the first
Super Mario RPG they gave it the square
enix a square Enix produced the game all
right so it's not like this is the first
time they're doing it they've done it
before with uh Mario himself Mario's
in various places Nintendo is still
controlling a narrative and they're
controlling how we play when we play and
why we play right when people start
voting with their dollars and showing
them every company in the world
I think Nintendo is the only Cup you
vote for your wallet probably less about
the online connectivity but if they come
through with those older games whatever
if that is official no I'm worried about
that now because these minis are killing
these streets no incentive for them to
give that to us now maybe you're like me
with an int NES mini a Super NES you
know now the 64 is coming when they when
they make back to the NES mini and
they're gonna get different games I'm
looking at my mini right now let's we
got company - what time's the raft is to
go before we move Oh get it over -
actually addict again because uh dusting
- actually dropped out so mom some PC
addict what's going on with destiny - in
this uh PC possible frictions
I mean I feel like I'll let you explain
this because I'm eating a jolly right
yeah I don't get you jealous what we're
seeing is the weekly update came out
though basically Bungie put out a
statement and you know they were talking
about PC balance and they were talking
about the PC gaming community and how
they want to talk about um you know
basically controlling the whole hacking
and you know people being able to you
know manipulate the environment so one
thing they talked about was a lot of
third-party applications
you know ones that like put in allow
code to be injected into the game and
then they're in their pain in the wrong
hands that some applications are used
we'll add codes of game climate client
in the right hands that can enable some
nice features like over ladies getting
cash or things like that but he said in
the wrong hands this can be disruptive
to the world that they [ __ ] it's a list
of what is gonna be acceptable we're not
acceptable in the PC beta and I was
actually surprised to see some of the
stuff that was not allowed food game
capture mode OBS and xsplit was was not
supported um don't quote me I believe
there was also some voice communication
things like discord and mumble you know
that allow those notification and those
overlays are not compatible with destiny
2 now obviously I'm not the biggest PC
guy but I know that these are huge
features for the PC community that are
now not gonna be allowed in destiny 2 so
I want them bring it to the laws like
what do we feel about this in these
restrictions in budget oh I know I can't
wait for destiny to come out look on the
internet for them for the world to burn
always the caveat to bringing destiny to
the PC this is why they put it on
battlenet so they could control that
because even even dedicated servers get
hacked so you need to be really careful
about what you allows be used and then
the problem with this is a lot of other
games have multiplayer components
whether it be just the PV
P some some coop a ve destiny that is
all that is it is it is cooperative PvE
or PvP that is the game if you allow
this sort of stuff these sort of
applications to be able to be used on
that game the game within a week's time
within alliterated I mean really and
this is just the reality of how that how
PC gaming works Azam is have a quick
question real quick
what does Ike Ramez say about PC being
forced to play 30 frames though he's
joking he's like 30 frames per second
farad only then to see that benchmark
you don't know anything so they give you
the can they tell you right now we are
fitting a lot of you in your face liars
and cheats we don't trust y'all so you
won't be able to walk in here with your
arms we'll be taking your arms away but
on top of that no matter what it is
still the highest pre-ordered PC game so
far this year you say some early before
you were good yeah no I mean that was it
I mean that's that's the reason you're
gonna see this stuff and they're gonna
continue Naren tu as the game expands
more they add more expansions more raids
more stuff I trust me it's gonna get
even more strong because the thing is it
has the ability to break the whole game
not an aspect of the game right he's
adding cold let's add a coat and they
want to
you think it's more of a protection for
battlenet and achievers I mean I
understand the logic behind it because
those things act cold but I just I was
concerned cause I was like him so what
are they supposed to do you're a
blocking discord Howard dudes like
that's my thing like to me it became
unattractive like that's the plus side
to garden wall garden of the console
space ensures that sort of quote unquote
security right you're gonna be playing
with a set group of people and it's set
yeah and it's just it's controlled more
the PC is my West it always was a bigger
turn to join up so my question look at
it do you think the PC community will
Wow do you think like this I told you
I'm waiting for October whenever that
game comes out in October so I can look
on the internet and see the world burn
Street their money writes in front of
their actual place when it comes to PC
people meant they don't play you you've
been veneer you don't you don't go
that's gonna happen a whole lot sooner
than you think sir as soon as that demo
is released and these people these
hackers can't do anything they're gonna
see that and they're just gonna be like
there's no way they're gonna release the
game like that when the actual game
comes out and they actually put money
behind it and I don't even think I'm
looking at this deed this fine print and
it's like please note third-party
applications which repeatedly attempt to
insert code into the destiny to PC
client will potentially impact game
performance and they're telling people
to disable these features and I'm just
like that means shadowplay OBS all these
guys yeah
like so wait so so let me ask you this
because you really all be a skylight so
are they trying to say like you're not
gonna be able to Game Capture Game
Capture in windowed mode right it won't
be fullscreen it'll be windowed mode and
you can also Game Capture capture with
hardware solutions like El macho's
because I'm reading I saying okay if
they want to capture they gotta use
hardware capture through El Gato Avera
media or de PC this is one battle the PC
community's not gonna win because
activations just gonna believe look like
we gonna make the muddy regardless if
something you don't think when it comes
to pee look how many games Activision
actually launches on PC
they don't care the PC community you can
say what they want they'll be like then
it dies on PC called so this is gonna
sell more anyway this is interested
printed table and no loss table you got
one more for you wrap this thing up and
you want to talk about our blue Killing
Floor 2 correct oh yes like I mentioned
earlier so there was a little bit of
discussion around the announcement that
what Killing Floor 2 would be coming to
the x1 X with with specific enhancements
but then there was court of outcry that
the enhancements don't seem as big as
what will a what people expected and
even more so not a huge leap over what's
already available right now on the ps4
Pro right so on the ps4 protein for two
runs at 1800 peach eka boarded up scaled
to 4k and it runs at 60 frames per
second the developers are Killing Floor
2 indicated that when they they weigh
will report the game in the x1 X fairly
quickly in about 4 hours they said they
ported it over um and that it runs at
1800 P native at 60 frames per second
but when it they try to run it native 4k
um the frame rate dropped considerably
to the point where it was unplayable my
mind you
when they said this it was again they
hadn't put a lot of work into it but the
way the way they worded it it seemed
like they didn't intend on putting a lot
of work into it so that so basically
we're gonna see the game at 1800 P
native of scale right your to your TV
upscale it to 4k but it'll be running at
60 frames per second so again the big
argument people have it okay once again
it's showing that the x1 X is hamstrung
and it's not able to do these huge leaps
and again again we're beating a dead dog
with this we've been talking about this
over the course of which seems to be a
pattern we there's a pattern I think
what people gonna have to really
recognize about this system is you again
first party stuff they're gonna put the
work into it to make sure that it looks
fantastic and runs fantastic and we'll
see the biggest leaps in the first party
stuff and third party stuff is gonna be
up to the developer how much time they
want to they want to put into it and if
they don't if they don't put in a lot of
time they just do the the basic port
over in all likelihood we're not gonna
see huge jumps over what we see on on
opposing platforms and that's just it
that's the reality of it um so that's
something I think we just need we just a
narrative we need to get used to that's
it
Lord Lord King what do you feel about
this Killing Floor 2 fiasco and Lord
King knows we both we both been playing
cannon Floor 2 on the PlayStation yes
you know and Microsoft's problem was
when they said they they said 4k
uncompromised ok yeah true folks
uncompromised true 4k shoutout to Rick
and review Tech I sat there I watched
this whole thing on it um and these
people are killing the system man yeah
yeah going in the internet
oh I mean that's what happens when you
step your feet on PC chip face out yeah
yeah when you stick your face out they
say you'll be walking around with this
18 karat gold chain listen they painted
their self in this corner this fork a
corner and they gonna have to fight
their way out of it we don't we don't
know yet till it's in our house we have
months to go it's a reason why I didn't
launch early it's a reason for a lot of
things you can say FCC crap they can say
anything that they want I know they want
to put this off in the best position
that these games are running in for okay
I don't care if you get a checkerboard
wise I don't care how you do it I don't
care to be honest with you I'm really
sick of tired of this whole 4k
conversation my thing was all right just
have the option for 1080p 60 okay which
is what I feel game is really one I
think if they do that that is a small
thing to be honest with you there's a
small thing if it's not running it is a
hardware type of thing where you just
say boost mold whatever it boosters it
to 1080p 60 frames per second if your
TV's not outputting a 4k period every
game you do that you control the
narrative you take it away from this 4k
crap now 18 ATP great you upscaling to
to a 4k good it's running in 30 frames
per second fantastic
killing floors as twitch game u-turns
memorize you forward you shoot I'm
pretty sure that the people complaining
about it one don't have a 4k television
- don't plan on buying Killing Floor 2
anyway so is this a lot of people
talking crap and they probably not even
buying Xbox one X when the system is out
fine let us see then they're killing
this stuff many killing me I guess
what's surprising to me I don't know if
you guys remember
during the whole Xbox one reveal when
digital foundry had the exclusive and
they were talking about you know all the
things you can do and how impressive
everything went down to the the floors a
thing the I don't know solver don't see
if you caught this okay locating caught
it there was a thing that led Ledbetter
did and he started talking about how the
Xbox one X supposedly had this ability
to run like pseudo 60 frames per second
and it was kind of like I forgot the
technology I try to find the source
article but basically it was something
to the effect like if a game couldn't
reach 60 frame there was some type of
tricks that they can do to achieve it up
there jump in
he was talking about games that had open
frame rate yes or games they would
develop they would develop like a halo 5
with the variable framerate
he said that anything that had a
variable framerate then got up to 60
frames right they were dynamic in terms
of frame rate mmm
would be able to be locked in either 30
or 60 depending on what only for these
games that had he's alright if my brain
right oh that was something yeah it was
whatever game let's say in the cold it
targeted this frame rate right and for
the bottlenecks that was inside this
system they couldn't achieve that frame
rate even if it wasn't a variable if it
had dips you caught slowdown in certain
places those slowdowns and those dips
will be eliminated for the street the
sheer brute force of the system exactly
exactly
again but again for older games most
older games weren't developed with that
in mind right if you if you look on a
ps4 Pro now neo has that where neo
offers you the two different you gives
you the boost right and he offers you
the the high frame rate that the high
frame rate were at 1080p and it offers
you the the 1400 Peter
1800 feet um with the lower or whatever
with the UM with the slack with a 30
frames per second now the thing is and
but it allows you it allows you to
choose which frames per second you want
so that means that at a base level the
game's framerate is open and you can
just decide with a locket oh it actually
also has another it has another setting
specifically for the frame rate that
allows you to unlock it and run it that
way rather than locking it out of steady
30 or 60 so you can decide if you're
willing to deal with the dips and arises
by having it open that's another option
they could be moving forward but again
older games are not gonna have these
options I guess and I feel like
multiplayer that's definitely can I have
that option right at you
I guess yeah I got two loads this one
I'm struggling with it's like you know
Lord cop-outs I'm at a point in the
Chinese I get at the Montreux from the
Xbox one Nexus to let the developers
have the power to upgrade the game to
net benefits taking management so it
just like I'm struggling with this whole
mindset of you know the devs don't are
not going in you know I'm saying like
the controls no rules no restrictions
it's the same game any more money from
they're gonna give you the PlayStation 4
pro version they're just but but then
again the mantra of the ex is supposed
to be it's so easy it's almost like you
flip the switch in the lights come on
and you boost you stun that's the
problem that's the problem if killing
floor people made the game and they put
it over and they said oh we part it over
and apart-er over 1880 we don't know
optimization mr. Cole any developer lazy
man my feeling is this Microsoft's fault
for not being clear about this narrative
they don't want to say that because it
comes off as negative so they're never
gonna tell you know we can't do it right
so it's people like us sitting here
talking about it people on the internet
kind of digging deep and coming up with
the stuff for the narrative to become
clear so that's it's just going to
continue to happen that way and people
these articles are going to keep
happening well into when the X
he gets on release because it's good to
them keep happening but it is therefore
because if this is something as across
the board can it be happening just say
it and because everybody just say that
because I think about it is that we have
to again and they're talking about way
too much do you see 1800 because
remember the PlayStation joint was 1440
something native and then they
checkerboarded it's a yeah yeah and then
from there the TV and whatever else gave
it that extra postage so instead of
killing The Killing Floor 2 PlayStation
Pro they put a chest out for a year and
a half basically an advert come out
openly and say that we were wrong use
marketing terms they were wrong look
they just look at the spies marketing
they are very used to this so yeah when
I was the beta switch cuz they try to
make it seem like it was a lot you for
true 4k and then we're gonna we're gonna
switch up two or three months before it
comes out yeah to see if the narrative
like in terms of advertising and
marketing changes as we get closer to
the launch of the console if they see
that this is really affecting them
because because again like again bad
press is bad press you don't want to
hear that and the thing is you don't get
out in front of it you're gonna put this
up in that position where it's going to
keep happening and the thing is we need
to acknowledge this gamers is that
everything that's been released on this
Jen and and in terms of Xbox everything
back compat - it's gonna be beholden to
the limitations of that of that system
how the game was created on that system
if it was locked 30 you getting locked
30 if it was for whatever reason an
open-ended framerate you could get
higher than 30 or whatever it's just
gonna depend know though and on that
note you can get a wrap this thing up
good show for the Lords today we have to
bring that church that gaming realness
so it's good so just before we end this
thing out um new poll is gonna be this
week so I just wanted to say it's is
actually inspired by our very own Lord
King and the poll this week is gonna be
going up on an ALP Twitter it's gonna be
is the xbox preview program bad for
gamers of early access and helping a
smaller studio or do you feel it's
unpaid game asleep actually shout out to
my boy Lord salt the saltiest game would
check out his channel or a lot he put
out a video just recently kind of
compound what we talked about last week
about fortnight going in on xbox preview
forward so again I don't know what's
gonna go what'd I just say there are
some people who really of agree with
looking so that's good contentious topic
we need the people's opinion into the
Twitter will go up now before the vote
will go up and you guys got two days you
know what to do so um we're gonna do our
lo outros right quick Lord oh yeah
please vote it's gonna be a go
so Lord tell us what's going on with the
gaming out of Channel
follow me on Twitter YouTube and all my
gaming credential things but what are
your gaming credential me and kid are
about to launch a dual review format
that we're going to be reviewing games
as two people or not one so look out for
that ain't no and you know I've been
streaming a lot more on gaming at it so
you know if you like a lures to and
range of games definitely follow that
nice and I've been meaning to do
spotlights and stuff but I kind of want
to wait till after games gone to really
because I really want to do a crackdown
spotlight but because I feel like if I
do one now I'm just gonna have to do
another one after games going people who
find me on xbox live at the xrn PSN big
sovereign one word and on Twitter Lord
sovereign IOP Lord style io p on that
quick shoutout also to big ex boss dude
every Sunday man bright and early man's
ready to go yeah he's gonna chat lit out
of Haven big boss though that we met him
shout out the big boss because a lot
Attica actually we met him at e3 we were
on the Destiny two line correct I forgot
he really good God knows his gaming
knows his stuff and he always reps that
ILP branch we bringing that church on
Sundays he's only thanks to everybody in
the chat to man you guys are great and
you guys will go go ham and they can't
stand the people in the chat because
anchorman so happens to be one look you
can find people find you sir good catch
weird it's the Facebook Twitter but you
can catch me Thursday
maybe the game I'll allow if they do
then listen kid I'll give you something
I'll tow you a bone sir since you put
your head out there if you play with a
female NBA team WNBA and I play with an
NBA team if you beat me I will buy you
the game even if you lose the game so
like if you lose he said no no no I said
even if he if he loses the bet cuz he's
gonna lose the bet I'm gonna destroy
destroyed what if he happens to beat me
with that team then fine you know he can
get the game because right now it stands
if he wins lose or whatever all he's
doing is behind me the game if he wins
he gets nothing
so if he wins and he beats me with a
WNBA team I'll buy him the game
you buy the game so basically just I
know Cassie of course I can see me
spending that game around us and how can
we appreciate everybody showing up on
Sunday for that chunk yeah ring today
this week I know again please hit that
like subscribe to I appear in all the
media media outlets YouTube SoundCloud
iTunes all that good stuff all that
really
helps us supports the whole support of
the Lord is much appreciated we got some
stuff cooking that we can't talk about
it too deep just yet but we're gonna be
very surprised I think the fans of the
Lord's and a round table can be very
surprised and very excited so we
definitely got some more stuff to talk
about and anything else we want to close
out with Lord addict before we wrap this
thing up yeah look out for some hell
blade impressions next week we're gonna
be talking about Hell blade I'm
definitely that note we are out of here
please